you're very active on on Twitter and I
love on your Twitter bio you say I'm not
as obnoxious as my tweets because you
really like to sort of walk the line
sometimes and your tweets is that fair
yeah I say some things on Twitter that I
don't know now I'm just thinking about
it I'm like maybe I am as if noxious as
my tweets would you say when you're
tweeting do you think about it first or
do you do I'm like you know I like when
people will like get drunk they like
texture X's I tweet go and Twitter right
now I'm sweet in that right so you if
you've had a few or you're in a certain
state you'd like to go on on Twitter and
just say stuff you ever look at it the
next day and go oh my god I can't
believe I said that
no sometimes I look back and I'm like
Kiera see that was that was really that
was genius you're really funny we have
we have you posted a video on Instagram
and I'm going to assume that you're in a
state you were a heightened state in
this video and medication you're in a
heightened state yeah and you put this
out there and it looks like you is this
your dog in there yes let's take a look
[Music]
look at your dog is looking at
I love that your dog is like the one
that's acting mature like hey let's just
let your dog
they patter your dog and your dog is
like I hear I don't condone this I think
she should hydrate